[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
dedicada al análisis de la situación
internacional este próximo domingo los
chilenos acudirán a las urnas para
decidir por vía de un plebiscito si
reforman o no la constitución que data
de 1980 aprobada durante la dictadura
militar que encabezaba el general
augusto pinochet porque estos cambios
quienes oponen a esas reformas cuáles
son los escenarios que se pueden esperar
a partir de este voto del domingo para
hablar de ello saludamos ya a nuestros
invitados
paola martínez periodista chilena
bienvenida a la gracia se limitase a
rubén curiel periodista independiente
bienvenido y cecil falles geógrafa
especialista en teorías de producción y
medio ambiente en particular de chile
bienvenida
bienvenidos a todos plebiscito
constitucional en chile estamos en
primera plana
las movilizaciones en favor del
plebiscito constitucional comenzaron
hace un año exactamente en octubre del
2019 y vale la pena ver lo que decía la
prensa de ese momento y lo que dice
ahora esa misma prensa comenzamos con el
tabloide chileno la tercera del domingo
que en octubre del 2019
abría su portada con el título la crisis
que nadie previó pocas semanas después
en la vecina argentina página 12 título
evocando las palabras del presidente
salvador allende del 11 de septiembre de
1973 se abrirán las nuevas grandes
alamedas cuando esta magnífica
fotografía mostrando una multitudinaria
concentración de más de un millón de
personas en santiago de chile y que
sucede un año después el 18 de octubre
pasado el periódico marca mercurio el
principal periódico de chile título
marchas y cortes marcaron el primer
aniversario del 18 de octubre y acabamos
con publimetro que escribió un año
después chile pide ser escuchado
paola comienzo con usted lo que estamos
viviendo ahora lo que se vive en chile
desde hace un año significa una
duras de la sociedad chilena
indiscutiblemente el chile hoy día está
viendo la profunda transformación social
política
'esperemos económica en el futuro pero
es verdad que esta crisis que vemos hoy
día que hace un año que existe es algo
que se preveía porque desde hace mucho
tiempo atrás los chilenos y chilenas no
creen más en la institución política hay
una ruptura con el estado en ruptura con
un estado que no hace nada un estado que
no escucha sus reivindicaciones ya lo
habíamos visto con movimientos
anteriores de los pingüinos los
movimientos nosotros el movimiento
contra la afp los fondos de pensiones
contra las jubilaciones y esto que pasó
hoy día es realmente como la gota que
desborda este vaso de un hartazgo total
frente a esta institución que no hace
nada que una una clase política que está
completamente desconectada de la
realidad del dolor chileno un grupo de
parlamentarios que gana millones
cuando la gente gana muy poco dinero con
una clase de privilegios frente a una
clase sin ninguna oportunidad entonces
lo que está viviendo hoy día el pueblo
de chile es cierto
es una profunda transformación social y
política y marca realmente una ruptura
se diría que hoy día nació un suerte de
individuo anarquista que no cree la
institucionalidad que no cree en un
estado garante de nada porque el estado
hasta el momento no ha garantizado nada
al pueblo chileno entonces si
efectivamente está viviendo un proceso
de ruptura constitucional
el titular de la tercera del domingo
dice la ruptura o las protestas la
crisis que nadie previó paola dice que
estaba previsto esto cuál es opinión
pues también parece que el corazón en
las protestas es el mismo que en 2011
por ejemplo empezaron los jóvenes pero
ahora están acompañados por diferentes
franjas de la población en hace rato que
los chinos nos piden el cambio de este
sistema y ahora me parece que todo chile
va a la calle para preguntar por ese por
este cambio a mí me parece no me parece
no me parece que es que fue imprevisible
porque lo dice para hace rato que los
chilenos piden por ese cambio
un verdadero cambio un cambio drástico
es decir hay estos pasos o estos puntos
negativos pero al mismo tiempo chile es
el país de mayor desarrollo general
global de américa latina el de mayor de
ingreso promedio la el punto fundamental
donde iban los capitales de inversión
privados y de repente parece que el rey
se quedó desnudo que ha sucedido
bueno la verdad es que
era previsto no en esta forma de
desarrollo muy brutal en un día para un
estudiante que está pasando
el precio de un ticket de metro
pero todos los investigadores geógrafos
sociólogos que trabajábamos en chile
desde hace 10 15 años sabíamos que algo
iba a pasar hay mucha y media lidad
mucha desigualdad perdón mucha
injusticia
ambiental social y ahí va a pasar algo
seguramente vamos a volver un poco atrás
creo que vale la pena para seguir con
este debate y recordar lo que sucedieron
en los últimos 40 años en chile en
septiembre de 1973 se produce el golpe
de estado que derrocó al presidente
constitucional salvador allende llegó
una junta militar que se va a instaurar
durante 16 años en 1980 augusto pinochet
ya nombrado presidente decide lanzar una
propuesta por la reforma de la
constitución que databa de 1925 y en
este sentido mi pregunta sería porque
pese al hecho de que más del 60% de la
población de entonces participó de ese
voto
por algún sector de la población se
considera que esa constitución es
ilegítima e ilegítima una porque fue
creada en dictadura que más ilegítimo
que eso hay un solo personaje que dicta
y designa todo lo que le va a conceder
en sus intereses en esa constitución de
1980 el estado va a ser un estado
subsidiario a partir de ese momento van
a perdonar ante todo la libertad de
empresarial chile se transforma en un
estado mercantil donde todos los
derechos básicos van a ser mercados
vamos a ver exactamente entonces qué
pasó hoy día a 30 años hay que olvidar
que la democracia llegó en 1990 después
una sucesión de partidos de la
concertación que es la está esta
izquierda plural que existía hacia
cuatro partidos cuatro partidos en 2005
no en el 89 una pequeña reforma en 2005
una reforma también de la constitución
con el gobierno de ricardo lagos cierto
con algunos matices sociales por
supuesto pero el pilar fundamental de la
constitución es un pilar que está basado
en un neoliberalismo que se fue
importado por los chicago boys en los
años 80 cierto en chile hoy día la gente
ya no sé
no sé no se siente involucrada en ese
proceso porque está claro que el proceso
neoliberal que hoy día hay se ha hecho
tan mal a la población que ha generado
esas desigualdades absolutas donde la
brecha entre el más rico y el más pobre
es sideral en chile el más rico gana 7
veces más que el más pobre el chileno
está endeudado 10 veces su salario esos
signos hoy día son indicadores potentes
en la cual uno se da cuenta que la
constitución de 1980 sentó las bases de
esa economía neoliberal que hoy día
tanto mal hacia la población chilena por
eso es necesario y fundamental cambiarlo
uno porque fue crean dictadura hoy día
chile es una democracia todo el mundo se
se jacta y se felicita de que una
democracia entonces en democracia
hagamos una constitución que esté de
acuerdo a los intereses del pueblo
hay que saber que en el año 80 por
ejemplo en ningún momento la ciudadanía
estaba considerada en esa constitución
del años 80 el ciudadano como gestor
como motor de cambio es considerado como
un ente aparte el chileno ya no es un
chileno ciudadano irresponsable es un
consumidor entonces esa es ese cambio es
fundamental hoy día no
en masa los chilenos como consumidores
sino como ciudadanos enteros capaces de
cambiar y de decidir por ellos mismos
antes de dar ese paso es decir
efectivamente se produce en el
referéndum en 1989 la mayoría de la
población decide que pinochet no puede
continuar en el gobierno a partir de ahí
como señalaba paola viene la llamada
concertación una coalición de cuatro
partidos nos vamos a detener mucho en
eso el hecho es que esta concertación
gobernó chile durante 20 años y a partir
del 2000 tuvo mayoría absoluta en el
parlamento primero con el presidente de
lagos lagos perdón después con la
presidenta michelle bachelet porque no
se modificó entonces la constitución
hubo al menos ocho reformas de la
constitución entre el 2000 y el 2020
para los temas esenciales que son agua
tierra y
recursos naturales y no es nada es el
cobre y cada vez más litio
hay tres códigos código de agua código
de minero y código de las tierras o sea
de que la ley de reforma agraria es un
poco complicado también tiene una
historia y existen a partir del 81 83 85
y siguen iguales no no hay cambios
porque
deberían justamente proteger un parte un
sector de la economía que es el cobre y
que chile él tiene 40 aportaciones y
para exportación tiene 40 por ciento de
los recursos mundiales del govern y es
muy importante en nuestras economías del
numérico etcétera entonces es un recurso
fundamental para chile este cobre es
nacional sigue nacionalizado pero hay
excepciones
o sea hay dos empresas que se comparten
los recursos para el cobre para el litio
y eso no ha cambiado porque es el
recurso con que chile se financia
durante la dictadura después de la
dictadura
y hasta ahora rubén a este propósito una
de las críticas o de las muchas críticas
que se hacen a la constitución de 1980
se dice como lo señala paola como lo
señala es decir es una constitución muy
liberal está la privatización de la
educación
luz etcétera pero por ejemplo en el caso
de los fondos de pensiones todo américa
latina se generalizó con los fondos de
pensiones en américa latina también en
la privatización de la educación
entonces cuál es la particularidad
finalmente de manera muy resumida por
favor pues como dijo para en el
principio de el programa el chile fue
como el laboratorio de un sistema
liberal en toda américa latina o sea con
los chicago boys como lo explicó i y
chile se fundó con esos con esos
principios y es muy complicado de
cambiar la constitución es muy rígida o
sea para cambiar la constitución
tienes que tener en un tercio
o tres quintos de los diputados y dos
senadores me parece así que es un cambio
muy complicado para para hacer
simplemente pero es que no hay nada que
rescatar después de 20 modificaciones de
la constitución
la verdad no te creo me parece que hay
que preguntar a la gente chile
en francia no no no no siento cómo como
lo siente un chileno para por ejemplo
pongo para hablar en 30 segundos no hay
nada que rescatar de la nueva
constitución hay que respetar un poco la
estabilidad entre comillas que permitió
que chile saliera de una dictadura de
democracia de manera con la cabeza en
alto por una parte pero ahora uno se da
cuenta que efectivamente el pilar
económico es lo que hoy día provoca esta
crisis entonces eso hay que cambiarlo
este es el ese es el tema central
permite una estabilidad durante un
tiempo de pasado una dictadura una
democracia no es fácil para ningún país
entonces esta condición permitió esa
transición sin embargo hoy día nos damos
cuenta de que ya no basta ss ese colchón
de estabilidad sino que ahora hay que
cambiar las cosas de raíz muy bien pues
vamos a hacer una pausa no se vayan
porque la segunda parte vamos a discutir
quiénes están detrás de esa movilización
cuáles son los efectos sociales y cuáles
son los escenarios que se pueden abrir
después del voto del próximo domingo
quédense con nosotros volvemos en unos
instantes aquí en primera plana
[Música]
ah
el creador de la marca y de las tiendas
de ropa zara amancio ortega es el hombre
más rico de españa y el decimotercero
del mundo según la revista forbes que
estima su fortuna en unos 60 billones de
dólares una fortuna amasada mediante su
imperio textil el grupo inditex que ya
cuenta con más de 7 mil tiendas a lo
largo de todo el mundo pero al mismo
tiempo que amancio ortega multiplicaba
las tiendas zara a lo largo de todo el
planeta exportaba también el modelo fast
fashion basado en un consumo de la ropa
con la concepción han de comprar prendas
a muy bajo coste para luego usarlas
durante un corto periodo de tiempo
mientras sean tendencia para
prácticamente tirarlas y volver a
comprar y es que zara renueva hasta dos
veces por semana sus tiendas y esta
incitación extrema del consumismo en el
mundo de la moda va ligada también a un
modelo de producción ampliamente
criticado por distintas organizaciones
internacionales por un lado por el alto
impacto medioambiental de este tipo de
industria y por otro lado por el impacto
social muchas han sido las denuncias de
los pésimos derechos laborales en los
talleres del sur global
proveen a este gigante textil
[Música]
en china los tres hombres más ricos se
elevaron sus ganancias a niveles récord
en 2020 la que es considerada la versión
china de la revista forbes señala que
sólo este año y como consecuencia de la
pandemia mundial por coronavirus sus
fortunas han crecido más que en el
acumulado de los cinco años anteriores
hablamos de jackman el fundador de
alibaba cuyo patrimonio está valorado en
casi 59 mil millones de dólares y es el
hombre más rico del país asiático en
segundo lugar aparece el fundador de la
empresa de internet tencent conima quien
acumula 57 mil millones de dólares y el
tercer lugar es para xiang chen chang
que con su exitoso negocio de agua
embotellada nunca ha podido amasar una
fortuna de casi 54 mil millones de
dólares de acuerdo con un informe
elaborado por el segundo banco más
grande de suiza el credit suisse china
es el segundo país con más millonarios
del mundo después de eeuu en total son
57 millones
[Música]
en esta famosa lista de la revista force
aparece en el número dos bill gates que
vive aquí en la costa oeste de los eeuu
con 98 billones de dólares un poco más
abajo en palo alto al norte del estado
de california en el número 7 está mark
zuckenberg con una fortuna alrededor de
los 54 billones de dólares este año en
esta famosa lista de la revista force
hay 58 millonarios - que perdieron mucho
dinero durante la época de la pandemia
la lista fue hecha el pasado mes de
marzo de los billonarios que están en la
lista
la gran mayoría perdió dinero un 51 por
ciento de ellos perdió dinero y entre
todos los de esta famosa lista suman 8
trillones de dólares
[Música]
sarajevo managua vale ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre la dictadura o catástrofes
naturales fukushima gross y la habana
france24 vuelve a las regiones que
marcaron la actualidad internacional sus
habitantes cuentan su nueva vida sus
esperanzas y su lucha para superar un
pasado traumático
boleto de vuelta una serie inédita de
reportajes en france 24 y france 24
puntocom estamos de vuelta ya aquí en
primera plana en compañía de nuestros
invitados paola martínez periodista
chilena de rubén curiel periodista
independiente y de cecil falles geógrafa
especialista en teorías de producción en
particular en chile
paola hay un sector de la población
perdón
paola de este lado hay un sector de la
población aproximadamente un 20% que
parece estar en contra del cambio de la
constitución sí porque porque lo que
decía anteriormente la constitución
genera estabilidad entonces la gente no
quiere que le cambien esa estabilidad en
general la gente que rechaza el proceso
constitucional hoy día son los más
pudientes son aquellos al cual el
sistema de extractivismo que mencionaba
cecil anteriormente que el sistema
liberal que hoy día permite que mucha
gente se enriquezca por ejemplo les va a
ser un poco movido del piso no va a ser
unos arte de terremoto a todos esos
privilegios que existen hoy día en esa
clase pudiente que no quiere ese cambio
estructural porque como lo decía
anteriormente en la constitución chilena
de 1980 que rige hoy día el país es una
constitución en la cual el estado un
estado subsidiario el estado no tienen
ni una
pero donde el especial [__] que tocar
ninguna opinión que dar respecto a la
industria el mercantilismo al comercio
entonces el que brilló el eje aquí el
que tiene el dinero entonces hay mucho
interés económico detrás de eso pero
esta gente que hoy día rechaza no
quieren ese cambio incluso se habla de
una manera bastante exagerada de que si
se cambia la constitución chile se
transformará el nuevo venezuela o tal
vez la situación argentina que son es la
teoría del miedo a no aquí hay que dar
miedo a la gente meterle miedo a los
otros para que no vayan a votar para
entender lo que es el estado subsidiario
simplemente no cabe recordar que es en
teoría económica y en la práctica el
estado no debe intervenir ahí donde el
capital privado puede hacer exactamente
es el caso chileno y no teóricamente en
la práctica altos estado subsidiario si
interviene es para ayudar siendo felices
y para él el gran capital de estas
empresas ahora bien si habíamos hablado
rápidamente de la juventud es esta
juventud la que genera con las protestas
contra el incremento del precio del
ticket del metro lo que estamos viviendo
ahora y finalmente lo que veremos el
próximo domingo en el plebiscito pero
hay una cuestión que llama mi atención
muchos de esos jóvenes no van a poder
votar no van a poder votar porque el
próximo domingo no tienen la edad para
votar o porque simple y sencillamente
algunos de esos jóvenes no creen en esta
forma de solución y hay que recordar la
movilización está generada por una
juventud que va desde los 12 hasta los
25 años más o menos una juventud que no
vivió la dictadura una juventud que no
vivió el momento de la constitución de
1980 pero que lo cual son las
expectativas de esa juventud finalmente
bueno hay una parte bueno nos podemos
interesar en la parte que no va a votar
pero hay una parte que va a votar y la
mayoría si es la mayoría y esta mayoría
bueno sufre del aumento del ticket del
metro pero también sufre del del alto
nivel del precio de las matrículas
universitarias y de la enseñanza también
media y básica porque tienen hermanos
chicos tienen hermanos mayores que los
padres se endeudan o que ellos mismos en
deuda
mucho mucho mucho para para poder
estudiar y no tener a veces después
empleos públicos porque hay muy pocos
empleos públicos entonces estables
entonces cuál es la expectativa es un
empleo precario con lo que se está
llamando la utilización del trabajo a
esta precariedad que realizado
generalizada y que ya estaba muy fuerte
en chile hace 15 años y que sigue bueno
cada vez peor digamos vamos a entrando
porque el tiempo va muy rápido vamos
entrando en lo que pueden ser las
perspectivas las expectativas que se van
a abrir y rubén hay dos preguntas dos
preguntas perdón que se plantearán a los
chilenos el próximo domingo la primera
es quiere usted una nueva constitución
seguida de la alternativa a prueba o
rechazo
en este caso se da por hecho que la
mayoría de los participantes del
plebiscito tiran a prueba el sí la
segunda es más difícil la segunda dice
qué tipo de órgano debería redactar la
nueva constitución acompañada de las
respuestas
convención vista constitucional o
convención constitucional cuál es la
diferencia entre una y otra convención
mixta constitucional y convención
constitucional la convención
constitucional está integrada por 118
155 miembros en los cuales serán 100 al
100% electos
por la ciudad ciudadanía en abril del
próximo año me parece el 11 y fecha de
la fecha contemplada también para la
selección de alcades etcétera extra y en
cambio la comisión mixta está integrada
por 50 150 por ciento de parlamentarios
y se cuentan por cientos de ciudadanos
directores reglamento que a través de
una votación popular
perdona y ese es el punto central porque
si la gente vota convención mixta por
ejemplo y hoy día rechazan injustamente
esa clase política que no ha hecho nada
por ello entonces le están pidiendo a
todo el mundo que si aprueban pero
tienen que hacer convención
constitucional que dice que las bases de
la gente que sean orgánicos porque hay
que decir algo muy importante chile y
general cuando vemos las noticias vemos
la gente peleando
en eros atacando en fin la violencia que
ha sido tremenda y condenables sin
embargo detrás de eso hay un pueblo que
se ha organizado desde el principio en
cabildos todos los sectores la población
la salud los audiovisuales los
profesores todo el mundo se organizó en
diferentes sectores de la población para
discutir qué cosas nuevas podemos
cambiar en este país que podemos aportar
nosotros como ciudadanos incluso lo
decía anteriormente no consumidores sino
ciudadanos responsables cómo podemos
cambiar nuestro país y hay una palabra
que es maravillosa en este bien este
movimiento queremos un país digno qué
significa eso es aprobemos con dignidad
no están pidiendo lo que desea yo
anteriormente en un mercedes benz de
tener más dinero que se yo quieren vivir
dignamente entonces en este en este
contexto la convención constitucional es
importantísima porque está la base que
es la población que está pidiendo que
está en la calle hoy día hace un año
están pidiendo cambios y que lo que
dicen las encuestas cuál de las dos
podrías pasar dice que las dos podía
pensar igual hay miedo todavía no hay
que olvidar que los procesos electorales
en general siempre son periodos muy
ambiguos anteriormente porque mucha
especulación
sin embargo el apruebo seguramente según
las encuestas va a ganar en un 70 por
ciento el punto del segundo que queremos
que cómo se hacen las cosas si una
convención mixta o si una convención
constitucional y es allí donde la
educación ha hecho mucho digamos el
común concientizar a la gente como
explicarles que es de lo que está
pasando hoy día necesitamos que en
realidad el pueblo que elija y no los
parlamentarios el riesgo de la comisión
mixta es que son los parlamentarios
actuales que están en el gobierno mucho
con lobby con intereses económicos marco
económico etcétera que pueden tal vez
influenciar no querer cambiar toda la
constitución dejar algunas leyes de
amarre dejar algunos pilares de esa
constitución de los años 80 y que
todavía hace tan mal el pueblo el albert
país perdón entonces lo que quiere la
gente es eso una convicción
constitucional muy bien ahora bien una
de las cosas que han estado acompañando
este proceso que dura ya más de un año
efectivamente tiene que ver con la
violencia lo vimos en las portadas al
inicio de esta emisión es decir según
cifras oficiales hay hoy en día más de
12 mil detenidos hubo 31 muertos
oficialmente y se registran más de 460
casos
que perdieron un ojo o que perdieron la
vista por disparos de la policía
claro que hubo también heridos del otro
lado pero mi pregunta sería esto se ha
dado se ha llegado aquí en un marco de
violencia se le puede adjudicar al
estado se le puede adjudicar a sectores
radicales hay una posibilidad de que
estas personas que son víctor finalmente
puedan ser indemnizadas que haya
justicia hacia ellas después del proceso
constitucional y hay que cerrar ese
expediente desde su punto de vista y es
una pregunta mayor que también
tendríamos que reflexionar en francia el
movimiento de las chaquetillas amarillas
los arcos amarillos el ecos amarillos es
complicado
[Música]
yo sé que bueno un trabajo amplio se
hizo en chile de memoria después de la
dictadura
bueno para juicios organizar también
o rondas de expresión museos
de memoria y estoy pensando en el museo
gabriela mistral por ejemplo hay centros
donde se puede hablar entonces a lo
mejor bueno la gente podría utilizar a
este trabajo de memoria para
para que salía algo jurídico de eso pero
no es muy complejo no sé si el tiempo
entiendo que es muy complejo pero me
interesaría ahora una vez que hemos
abordado este tema que sin duda alguna
recurre las sociedades latinoamericanas
atraviesan las sociedades
latinoamericanas en la protesta lo vimos
en ecuador y en otros países pero como
el tiempo nos gana me gustaría centrarme
en una parte que es fundamental
disculpen ustedes que es el acuerdo por
la paz social y la nueva constitución
del 15 de noviembre dice que para
aprobarse la constitución se requerirán
dos tercios de todo el texto y que si
esto no es prevalecerán lo que son las
condiciones de la actual constitución
rubén que se puede esperar si
efectivamente los constituyentes en
cualquiera de las dos fórmulas que se
den no logran aprobar los dos tercios de
lo que serían el proyecto de nueva
constitución eso es lo que hablamos
antes es que es una constitución muy
complicada para modificar y creo que es
lo que el pueblo pie es que ese sistema
no funciona
que no funcione más así
para si rechazan este proyecto no creo
que no sé que puede pasar después pero
va a haber más protestas y más más más
protestas y no sé si el pueblo chileno
está dispuesto a parar esas protestas o
sea no tienen tienen el corazón en esas
protestas y creo que va a seguir si este
proyecto de nueva constitución no no
funciona paola a este respecto por
ejemplo digo constituyente no podrán
participar sindicalistas entre otras
cosas pero al mismo tiempo habrá paridad
entre hombres y mujeres no son
necesarios muy nuevos seres serían antes
y en ese sentido pero al final de
cuentas si no se logran los dos tercios
o al ve usted que sean las expectativas
los escenarios que se pueden abrir yo
concuerdo con mi colega que si el
hipótesis que no se pueda realizar la
gente va a seguir en la calle porque no
a clear eslogan chile despertó y no es
menor esa palabra chile despertó y
sevilla abrieron los ojos frente a un
sistema que no les conviene entonces la
constitución idea incluso muchos piensan
que el cambio la constitución si bien es
importante es sí
hacerlo no lo es todo porque no todo
está ahí todo está centrado ahí siempre
decimos que es el pilar del sistema
neoliberal y todo lo que hemos discutido
en el programa sin embargo hay mucha
gente que pienso hoy día también que
cambió la constitución no significa el
gran paso a dar es una parte importante
y simbólica cierto que en reventar la
tormenta mental
rompemos con la dictadura rompemos con
la herencia de pinochet que no es menor
en un país del que sufrió mucho esa
dictadura sangre sanguinaria que duró 17
años sin embargo hoy día si yo pienso y
espero que las cosas van a estar por el
mejor de mi país que si no es el caso de
que las cosas no se pueden hacer como la
gente quiere la gente va a seguir en la
calle porque no quieren soltar este
proceso histórico es un proceso
histórico que está viviendo chile hoy
día yo lo decía al principio una
profunda transformación social económica
y política que se quiere entonces no van
a dejar pasar esta oportunidad que por
fin la gente salió del letargo en el
cual la tenían durante estos 30 años
entonces esperemos que las cosas sean
por el mejor y esperemos que las
protestas siguen no con la intensidad de
violencia policial que ha existido hasta
el momento es decir una última pregunta
una respuesta muy rápida piensa usted
que la constitución puede acabar en un
pálido sueño
finalmente esta reforma constitucional
si no se logran los dos tercios de los
que venimos hablando de manera muy breve
por favor
es muy complicado contestar eleccionario
está abierto muy abierto yo creo y está
entre los manos de los chilenos que van
a votar el domingo
rubén
como dije a mí están a mí me parece que
nos van a seguir prestando sí sí sí toca
muy bien espero en paz sobre todo pues
estamos llegando ya al final de ésta en
primera plana no me queda sino
agradecerles a paola rubén y cecil su
presencia en nuestros estudios y estamos
en primera plata
[Música]